In the final part of our tutorial we're going to talk about ways to optimize smoke, liquid,
and fire effects.
And the manner in which we're really going to primarily focus has to deal with taking
our very complex fire, smoke, or liquid effects and baking them down into a series of images
that can then be played back in real time to give the illusion that this really complex
behavior is happening when in fact we are basically pre-computing that behavior to a
texture frame by frame and then playing it back.
This is commonly for all the flip book, but here is what the texture would look like.
So we'd start it here at frame zero and we'd go eight by eight, which would give us 64.
So this is it turning on and then going down and we would get something, it's not video
here, but something like this that we can then play back.
Now to do this inside of Niagara, it's actually very simple.
All we need to do is come up to the editor and the effect we want and enable the baker.
Once we click on the little button, we're going to get exposed some tools that will
allow us to basically select our file name, position a camera, set the size that we want
the output object to, and then actually render that out.
And here's an image of that work.
Or I should say tool set.
Let's go ahead and pop over to the editor and look at how to do this.
I'm going to hit control space.
I'm going to bring up my NS gas fire and just double click on it.
Remember, we can do this with pretty much any effect.
Just keep in mind that some effects will be easier to capture than others.
Again, we're going to bring up our baker here.
So there we go.
I'm going to come down and do the front viewport.
It's just going to make it easier to kind of like zoom in on stuff.
And I don't know why it is not.
There we go.
I'm going to go click back to perspective to zoom in a little bit.
It will not be this crazy when we go to look and render this out.
Sorry, I'm horrible at saying and working on stuff at the same time.
So here we go.
We're going to set this to 512 by 512.
This should give us a little bit more resolution.
There we go.
And then if we come down to, there is a camera setting here somewhere that will allow us
to adjust our previews.
And maybe I'm not.
Ah, here we go.
That's what I was looking for.
It's right next to it.
The reason I want to do this is I want to bring this down a little bit so I get the
smoke a little bit closer.
There we go.
The smoke and the fire.
All right.
We're also going to give this a name of, call this T underscore fire underscore sub UV.
And then when we're ready to bake this, all we need to do is press this little bake button
here.
This is really cool.
It's going to bake it and then we're going to see it rendered out right here.
It just needs a second to stream in.
But this is the textured output.
We can actually look at that.
There's our texture right here to save all the alpha.
So you can see here it starts and then goes all the way down through.
What we're going to do next is we are going to make a material out of this.
All we need to really do is just change the blend mode to translucent and then connect
the alpha here into the opacity.
So let's do that now.
So we're going to right control space to open up the content browser.
Right click.
We're going to look for our material.
I go this mat underscore sub UV underscore fire.
And let's double click on that to open it up.
And I'm just going to select this right here.
And a quick way to quickly add this is to hold down the T key and left click that I
have that texture sample.
We're going to click the RGB into base the A and to our opacity and then set our blend
mode here to translucent, which maybe we are RGB A. There we go RGB A and let's hit apply
and save.
So that is good.
The next thing that we need to do is we're going to make a new particle system inside
of the learning content.
We're going to select a sub UV animation and hit create.
And let's go ahead and do that now.
So again, right click Niagara system.
We're going to come here to learning content and then our sub UV animation.
We're going to hit create in S underscore fire sub UV.
Then let's double click on that to open it up.
And all we need to do to this is just change the material.
We're going to enable cut out cut out as a way to optimize the unused part of your
translucent geometry.
It basically cuts the geometry to fit more or less kind of the outline of your smoke
or your fire.
This is a way to just optimize this in our particular case.
This isn't going to matter as much as it would if we were using multiple effects.
But anyway, we're going to set that up and then we're also going to change the uniform
sprite size to 500 to make it a little bit larger.
So let's go ahead and we can close the baker for now.
And then our system overview right here are material.
I'm going to hit control space.
We're going to grab our mat sub UV fire.
Bring that in right there.
Okay.
And that's actually our fire working right there.
Now there are a couple of other things.
So we can do our cut out.
Up there it is right there.
And what we'll need to do is change this to the red channel.
And that will give us our cut out here.
All right.
And then we're going to go to our initialize particle and set our size here to 500.
It's going to make things a little bit bigger.
So we'll compile and save that.
And I'm just going to move this out of the way so I can bring it into the world.
So there we go.
There is our fire.
And he does not seem to be working for some reason.
Let's save this and browse really quick.
Oh, it's because I have real time off.
There we go.
You need to turn that real time renderer back on.
And there is our fire.
Let me just delete this.
So there we go.
Again, it's not looking the best because I just did a very simplistic render.
But if you were to apply a little bit more time and a few other just a couple of these,
you could get some actual really good results using this particular method.
And again, this is extraordinarily cheap compared to running the actual fire effect like this
right here.
So you know, you are losing a little bit of depth and things like that.
But again, this could be used as something like, you know, for a level of detail when
it's really far away, something like that.
Or there's a bunch of use cases where being able to use the baker right here can really
help optimize your effects, no matter if they use liquid or just standard particle effects.
You can use this for any type of effect inside of Niagara to help optimize it.
So this is our end result.